welcome dr oz i'm so happy to be with
you
okay i know that a lot of us i know i
run away from certain subjects like we
were going to talk about the heart today
and i was like ugh
i'm scared so i want to face fears today
i want to get facts
and i want to talk about different
realms of life
because sometimes we think it's just
about diet and exercise and there's so
much more
like for example we're here sitting at
our desks how does
this space affect us
we're all in a home office right now and
i was wondering
if there are tips and tricks that we can
apply
to the place we're all confined in right
now
until we had all these newfangled
medications and concepts that you could
heal with steel
i.e surgery this was how we healed each
other
it's you know we've created environments
that's why style is so important
because it takes our bodies our minds
where we need to be but just take the
environment that you put me in here
because this is a bit more cluttered
than i would normally have it and
clutter messages something called
nuts nagging unfinished tasks
when you have nagging unfinished tasks
like you know that's that
porch door that slams on your butt yeah
you know every time you walk out you
never fix it
it actually creates this subtle but very
important elevation of cortisol the
stress hormone
and it again messages to you that you're
not in control of your destiny but if
you take care of this
space as you're caring for your space
you basically are doing self-care
you're messaging to you that you matter
so it adds up
and other things start to start to fall
in place your blood pressure doesn't go
up as high blood pressure we're going to
talk a lot about today because
the number one age of all is actually
your blood pressure and being able to
deal with the nagging unfinished tasks
in your life
again symbolized by the environment
you're in is one of the best things we
can do and everyone at home watching
the drew barrymore show right now can do
that and it doesn't cost you anything
okay so i'm gonna add more clutter to my
desk
i am gonna declutter i mean if you saw
the drew's news desk
you might have a heart attack ah
i've weight lifted i love this space
the final frontier this is perfect okay
this this does feel better you're right
dust off the edges there
what i got to say i love is this little
element here
because when you have greenery around
anywhere when you can bathe in the
forest and feel the life force the
energy
that you can lower your blood pressure
and actually begin some of the natural
self-healing that would occur if you
just get out of your way
same for pets having a pet and and
expressing affection for another living
entity
elevates you it connects us i actually
think that's the real epidemic that
we're facing
right now in america is the loneliness
epidemic but it's not just between each
other
we don't feel connected to the place we
are our planet
and as we begin to gather that and bring
that back into us that
that collective subconscious that we all
actually have
historically for the entire history of
our species we've always respected that
it is brought alive by taking care of a
plant or a pet or
carry for the human being i brought um
these fish here
they're bettas and you can literally buy
them at a pet store
they're solo livers they can't even live
with another they'll
fight to death and i just like the
beauty
and the zen-ness and the aliveness
of this tiny little being and i feel
like it has a big effect on me
am i crazy or is this actually a
scientific possibility
no you're not crazy at all in fact when
you sense when you have that gut
instinct never deny that we actually
have a whole
row of these in different colors of this
fish really yes and they were in
different colors and we know they all
had names and they had personalities
and again it's sort of cool to feel a
connection it can happen at any level
and the fact that they are solo is just
such a mirror image to what we're going
through
in society and the sort of poetry of
that
but they're just incredibly calming and
what does loneliness due to the body
we i think we are karmically designed to
be in community
and people who are lonely suffer from
elevated blood pressure again the number
one ager
they start to have elevated cortisol
levels they also start to have mood
abnormalities and
the loneliness is the the
symptom of it their antidote is to find
community is to find
a group that you can link up to because
humans have always been
the safety net for each other yeah
always do you think
that in a time where we are
told to shelter in place can you find
that community
outside of your home through technology
is it the same
i don't think it's the same but you can
approximate it i mean look
social distancing which is a horrible
phrase it should be physical distancing
it's something that has incredible
incredible impact if you can get
together with someone outdoors in any
capacity i walk with them
you can even sit down have tea with them
if you're outdoors
you can get away with a lot because the
spread of covid
is 20 times higher indoors than outdoors
but there's nothing like talking
like this however the next best is is to
hear
so literally picking up the phone and
calling somebody is immeasurably better
than texting
the thing you just said about we
shouldn't be calling it social distant
we should be calling it physical
distance
is a true aha moment for me
that is one of my favorite things that
i'm really going to carry with me
and you just got the vaccine yes and
how was that experience i had no issues
at all i got the first vaccine right
after you know i'm
i still practice i'm a surgeon at
columbia university at new york
presbyterian so
all the surges went we got our vaccines
but i tell you i feel like a huge burden
is lifted off me i can i mean i'm not
superman because i can still get
potentially potentially get the virus
but it's 95 percent effective which i
did we just don't have vaccines that
work that way normally now
the way you just said that it just
lifted up my belief and optimism
and now we actually have a vff question
would you mind taking it
i'm in all right tiffany um
what is your question so
organizing and decluttering is the thing
right now it's all over my social medias
and i've heard that organizing can
actually help you sleep better
is that true you're tiffany you're
really sharp that's exactly right
it's not just a little bit either people
who for example if you make your bed
you sleep 20 better so keeping the bed
environment
appropriate the sleep hygiene tools are
incredibly impactful 50
of the us population does not sleep well
it is the single
single most important underappreciated
health tip i can ever give
and what is one thing that we can do
today
to get better sleep that is
you know maybe not easy to hear but a
truth
for most people elevating the head of
the bed ever so slightly
and not just by putting pillows because
you'll roll off those you just put a
little block under your bed and
elevate the head a little bit it
actually helps with breathing snoring
acid reflux acid reflux which is a
gravity
and this thing helps with back pain
cramps i mean it's a lot of reasons for
that and i tell you it's impactful the
other little tip
a pro tip make sure it smells good in
your room it matters
so think about putting a diffuser or
something that makes your room smell
the way you like it it has to be smell
you enjoy you got to customize it but
there's some scents that are conducive
to better sleep
i have never heard that before super
femme and like i want to attack that
tonight
i want to be like okay um tiffany
thank you so much for your question um
okay
before we go will you help me uh bust a
myth dr oz
take it away okay you're sitting at your
desk all day
everybody is i heard this is like
really toxic it's the new cigarette
smoking oh gosh
actually for every hour you sit at a
desk you increase your mortality
by 11 get up every half hour walk around
do something every commercial break do a
sit-up or a push-up don't have to be big
or painful just
move you're not supposed to be sitting
like this all day long especially at
[Music]
work